Brody what do you want for lunch you
know for a few days I've been craving
some mac and cheese but I feel like it
never really fills me up you know a way
that you can make it a little more
satiating I do and I will
some craft dinner one cook your pasta so
this is starting to look like you know
the classic KD or mac and cheese for our
American friends I just want to know
what are you gonna do differently like
what are your hacks for this picking
picking things off this business as
usual gonna just like let that cheese
sauce melt in I like to add a little
extra protein with cottage cheese
it adds lots of protein it's cheesy it
really doesn't add any kind of flavor
but it makes for a richer sauce that
also has lots of good protein in it and
for some extra fats some mozzarella
bocconcini balls because who doesn't
want some melty ooey gooey cheese going
on to their mouth not only is this going
to be way more satiating but it is also
just like so much more delicious than
the OG check that out so that's looking
really good but I've learned a lot from
you and I know that this is missing a
little bit of fiber well you are in luck
Mike friend because I got some steamed
broccoli gonna turn off the heat fold
that bad boy in
I'm gonna fold in the cheese fold in the
cheese you fold it in
Abby what are you doing